(upbeat music)
- Hi, everyone, my name is Jesse,
and I'm an educator here
at the Peabody Museum.
Today, we're gonna be making
a butterfly ring or bracelet.
(silence)
So this is a very simple
activity that you can do at home.
For this, you'll need to have some paper.
You can use construction
paper or recycled paper.
You'll need something to draw with.
You can use a pen or a
pencil, crayons, or markers
if you have them,
some tape, and some scissors.
So let's get started.
So for this activity,
you can look at butterflies
in your backyard,
you can watch a video that
we posted from entomology
and check out some of the butterflies
that live in the tropics,
or you can look one up online or in a book
to decide what you'd like to draw.
I'm gonna just use my imagination today.
So the way you get started,
you're gonna draw a B
shape onto your paper...
(silence)
Just like that, just to get started.
It's okay if it doesn't look
exactly like a butterfly.
You're gonna take your folded paper
and cut out along the shape.
(scissors snipping)
Now we have the beginnings of
our sweet little butterfly.
So now you can color it in.
(crayon lightly scratching)
When you're happy with your drawing,
now we're gonna make the ring
for our ring or our bracelet.
So you can take the paper
that you cut out earlier,
and you're just gonna cut
a small strip of paper
off the top.
(scissors snipping)
And for this part, you
might need to ask a grownup
for some help to get it the right size
to be able to put it on
your hand or your wrist.
So when you have your piece of paper,
you're gonna fold it over onto itself
to make a little ring just like that.
(tape ripping)
You can take a piece of tape and stick it
onto the part where the ring closes,
and then you're gonna fold
the tape into the ring
to close it so you can
see it just like that.
This one's kind of small; I
think it'll fit on my finger.
So before you put it on,
you wanna take another piece of tape...
(tape ripping)
We're gonna create a second ring.
So take one edge, fold it
over, and stick it onto itself,
and you're gonna take your tape ring
and put it right onto your paper ring.
Now we can put our butterfly
on, and it will be ready to go.
There you go; great job, everyone.
Feel free to send us pictures
of the ones you make.
(bright music)